so for anyone who wants to become a
research scientist i would say nurture
your you're questioning spirit if you
will because it's all about asking
questions and it's all about really
thinking and critically thinking about
information so i would say nurture those
skills go volunteering the lab to do
research at an academic institution and
get into the field because they're the
technical skills that you want to learn
and set up as a basis but you also want
to think about processing the data
processing information asking questions
about what's known what's not known
what's understood what's not understood
how can I approach this fee feed
yourself there's so many places to get
information so many you know you've got
the science journal the nature journal
those are tough to read as a high
schooler but you've got the you know
chronicles of science education you've
got all these websites that you can go
to and just collect information if
there's something that you've been
curious about find out more you know dig
into the scientific questions you have
in your own life just you know jump in
and again